nun zum geschäftsbereich des
bundesministeriums für arbeit und
soziales und das wort hat für die
bundesregierung der bundesminister für
arbeit und soziales hubertus heil
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin schön dass sie wieder
da sind liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
putins über verlauf die ukraine zwingt
uns in vielerlei hinsicht zur
neuausrichtung unserer politik in den
letzten vier wochen haben wir als
bundesregierung schnell und entschlossen
notwendige entscheidung getroffen aber
ich sage auch putins kriegt man der
damen und herren kann und wird nicht
dafür sorgen dass für unsere haltung und
unsere werte aufgeben die neue
bundesregierung
neue bundesregierung steht dafür ein
dass er eine starke und solidarische
gesellschaft sind und bleiben nach innen
und nach außen gerade jetzt kommt es
darauf an den gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalt zu festigen gerade jetzt
geht es darum dass sich alle auf soziale
sicherheit in unserem land verlassen
können gerade jetzt geht es darum dass
wir besonders diejenigen nicht aus dem
blick verlieren wie es auch sonst in
anderen zeit nicht leicht haben wir
werden in diesen schweren zeiten die
werte unserer sozialen demokratie nicht
preisgeben meine damen dann ist unsere
feste überzeugung
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
mit dieser haltung müssen wir jetzt
diese krise meistern und das bedeutet
wir müssen klare prioritäten setzen es
ist meine aufgabe als arbeits und
sozialminister an
vor allen dingen dafür zu sorgen dass
bei all dem was wir tun sozialer
ausgleich herrscht und ich sage ihnen
ganz deutlich wo notwendig werde ich für
soziale gerechtigkeit in meinem anbau
streiken
drei dinge gilt es jetzt anzupacken
erstens dafür zu sorgen dass auch in
dieser neuen wirtschaftskrise durch
sichere arbeitsplätze soziale stabilität
entsteht und deshalb sage ich ihnen an
dieser stelle wir haben in der pandemie
den arbeitsmarkt robust durch die krise
gebracht und ich bin diesem bundestag
dankbar dass wir in den letzten tagen es
geschafft haben auch noch einmal
kurzarbeit regeln anzupassen mein ziel
ist auch durch diese krise den deutschen
arbeitsmarkt robust zu bringen wir
werden um jeden arbeitsplatz kämpfen
meine damen
zweitens es geht darum die sozialen und
die wirtschaftlichen folgen ab zufrieden
wir sehen heute massive
preissteigerungen nicht nur an der
zapfsäule sondern bei heizkosten bei
stromkosten auch bei lebensmitteln
wenn wir jetzt den nicht helfen die in
not sind dann verpassen wir unsere
aufgabe dann wird es schnell kalt in
unserem land und deshalb weigern haben
wir in den letzten wochen entlastungs
paket auf den weg gebracht um härten
abzufüllen nicht mit der gießkanne
sondern sozial ausgewogen mit dem
heizkostenzuschuss dem kinder sofort
zuschlag den zuschlag für menschen in
der grundsicherung der erhöhung der
steuerlichen des steuerlichen
grundfreibetrages mit der abschaffung
der eeg-umlage vorgestern nacht hat die
koalition noch mal eine große schippe
draufgelegt mit weiteren entlastungen
für arbeitnehmer und arbeitnehmern und
selbständigen mit einer energie
kostenpauschale in höhe von 300 euro als
zuschuss zum gehalt bzw
für selbstständige als absolut von der
steuern mit den familien zuschuss in
höhe von 100 euro für jedes kind in
deutschland mit der verdoppelung der
einmalzahlung auf 200 euro für
erwachsene leistungsberechtigte in den
sozialen grundsicherungssystem und mit
weiteren maßnahmen zur mobilität ich
sage weil das ein thema ist von vielen
diesen maßnahmen werden übrigens
rentnerinnen und rentner profitieren in
der grundsicherung wird der zuschlag
auch für die rentnerin brender gezahlt
die in der grundsicherung sind beim
heizkostenzuschuss sind 46 prozent
derjenigen die davon profitieren werden
rentnerinnen und rentner von vielen
anderen dingen auch wir kümmern uns um
die die es schwer haben in dieser zeit
und darauf kann sich jeder verlassen
und ihre kolleginnen kollegen diese
solidarität
die brauchen aber auch jene und das ist
mein dritter punkt jetzt als geflüchtete
bei uns schutz suchen da geht es erst
einmal um die akute versorgung den
menschen hier leisten viele bürgerinnen
und bürger in unserem land großartig
ehrenamtliche und hauptamtliche und ich
glaube ich spreche im namen des gesamten
hauses dass wir dafür herzlich dank
sagen
die menschen die vor putins krieg
fliehen aus der ukraine die brauchen
humanitäre hilfe und sofortige hilfe die
brauchen aber oft auch eine dauerhafte
bleibe perspektive dafür müssen wir und
werden wir einen schnellen zugang zum
arbeitsmarkt schaffen sprach und
integrationskurse haben wir geöffnet
aber wir brauchen auch schul und kita
plätze und wir müssen einen weg finden
die qualifikationen die viele menschen
auch mit sich bringt schneller
anzuerkennen ich werde deshalb in der
kommenden woche wirtschaft
gewerkschaften wohlfahrtsverbände bund
und länder an einen tisch holen um über
arbeitsmarkt integration zu sprechen
alle müssen jetzt an einem tisch und
alle müssen an einem strang ziehen
ich würde mal sagen es geht in erster
linie humanitäre hilfe
aber es geht auch darum da wo menschen
die chance haben zu arbeiten ihnen diese
möglichkeit auch zu schaffen ich sage
aber auch an dieser stelle sehr deutlich
wir werden als gesellschaft nicht
zulassen dürfen dass in dieser situation
die not von geflüchteten von
scharlatanen ausgebeutet wird und
deshalb auch eine klare ansage wir
müssen und werden dafür sorgen dass die
menschen die so viel durchlitten haben
jetzt nicht opfer von abzocke oder
ausbeutung auto in arbeitswelt
präsidentin meine damen und herren wir
haben es in der pandemie gesehen und
erlebt unser sozialstaat ist die
tragende säule für sozialen zusammenhalt
in unserem land für eine starke und
widerstandsfähige gesellschaft nach
innen und nach außen und deswegen sage
ich ganz klar wir werden es nicht
zulassen dass diese krise missbraucht
wird den sozialstaat zu schwächen ja es
ist richtig wir müssen und wir werden
mehr in die ausrüstung der bundeswehr
und die äußere sicherheit investieren
ich unterstütze das ausdrücklich aber
wir müssen auch in die menschen und die
soziale sicherheit investieren es darf
kein entweder oder geben denn wir
brauchen beides meine damen und herren
wir
äußere sicherheits und inneren und
sozialen frieden und wir dürfen nicht
rente gegen rüstung aus spielen in
dieser gesellschaft und übrigens auch
nicht geflüchtete gegen einheimische das
ist das was wir als interessenten gelten
und gerade deshalb ist es wichtig dass
wir andere aufgaben nicht vernachlässigt
wir werden den mindestlohn zum ersten
oktober auf 12 euro erhöhen damit
diejenigen die den laden am laufen hat
die hart arbeiten dieser gesellschaft
tatsächlich den lohn bekommen denn ihnen
auch zusteht
deshalb ist es übrigens auch richtig
dass wir die renten stabil halten und
zwar für alle generationen und deshalb
ist es auch richtig dass es um das thema
fachkräfte um die frage der ausbildung
der qualifizierung kümmern damit die
arbeitnehmerin arbeitnehmer von heute
auch die chance haben in zeiten des
wandels die arbeit von morgen zu machen
und deswegen ist es richtig dass wir für
mehr respekt und mehr soziale sicherheit
sorgen mit der einführung beispielsweise
der kindergrundsicherung und dem neuen
bürgergeld meine damen und herren die
krise zu meistern und für sozialen
fortschritt zu sorgen das ist der
gemeinsame anspruch von spd bündnis 90
und den grünen in der ampelkoalition
und das gilt und dafür werde ich
arbeiten erst recht was habe ich gesagt
nein
das ist so selbstverständlich für mich
für fdp spd und bündnis lösen
ich kann ihnen das ernsthaft ich kann
dir das auch ernsthaft nachweisen dass
der bundesfinanzminister christian
lindner schon vor dem
koalitionsausschuss deutlich gemacht hat
dass wir beispielsweise zuschläge
weitere auf die grundrichtung brauchen
dafür bin ich ihm sehr dankbar diese
koalition findet zusammen und tut das
richtige und dafür bin ich ihnen als fdp
besonders dank bei der mitspieler
meine damen und herren ich sage es noch
mal unterstreichen wir sind in
ernsthaften zeiten wir stehen vor sehr
großen herausforderungen
und wir müssen darauf achten dass unsere
gesellschaft diese krise
widerstandsfähig übersteht und dass wir
halt und stabilität übrigens auch gebend
für die vielen veränderungen die nach
dieser krise auch noch stadt sind werden
und deshalb kann man nicht
wirtschaftlichen erfolg ökologische
vernunft und soziale gerechtigkeit
gegeneinander ausspielen wir setzen auf
digitalen fortschritt wir setzen auf
ökologischen fortschritt aber das geht
nur mit sozialen fortschritt in
deutschland dafür arbeitete herzlichen
dank
[Applaus]
der nächste redner für die cdu csu
fraktion ist stephan stracke
die frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren es ist krieg
in europa dieser krieg berührt bewegt
erschüttert uns im herzen
um zu herzen öffnen unsere türen um die
vielen geflüchteten willkommen zu heißen
und schutz zu bieten und es ist
beeindruckend wie viele helfen beim
spendensammeln beim transport von
hilfsgütern in erst anlaufstellen oder
gemeinschaftsunterkünften und es sind
wieder die ehrenamtlichen die
wohlfahrtsverbände und organisationen
die hier an vorderster front stehen und
einfach anpacken es ist großartig ein
herzliches dankeschön an alle
helferinnen vom tresen
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
wir helfen versorgen organisieren wir
bluten schutzräume für die vielen
geflohenen die mütter mit ihren kindern
die große zahl an älteren oder menschen
mit behinderungen sie sollen und sie
dürfen hier bei uns ankommen unterkommen
und sich sicher fühlen und wir wollen
gerade kindern und jugendlichen
möglichst schnell wieder so ein kleines
stück weit normalität geben deshalb
brauchen wir auch eine schnelle
integration in kita und schule
wir brauchen auch eine psychosoziale
betreuung denn das was man erlebt im
krieg und auf der flucht das ist etwas
das lange nachwirkt und ja die die
können und wollen die den kopf frei
haben
denen bieten wir auch nach kurse an
denen bieten wir die
arbeitsmarktintegration am mit einem
breiten dienstleistungs und förderungs
angebot der bundesagentur für arbeit wir
stehen insgesamt vor einer großen
humanitären aufgaben die wir gestellt
sind das ein gewaltiger kraftakt und das
gelingt nur gemeinsam gemeinsam mit den
kommunen vor ort mit den ländern und
auch mit dem bund und der bund muss hier
seiner verantwortung gerecht werden denn
es geht um eine faire lastenverteilung
bei den kosten und auch bei der
verteilung der geflüchteten auf die
länder und innerhalb der europäischen
union und dazu bedarf es einer
systematischen und lückenlosen
registrierung hier ist der bund am zug
er muss seiner verantwortung auch an
dieser stelle gerecht werden
der krieg hat tiefgreifende folgen
humanitäre und wirtschaftliche die
wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen sind
immens und werden jeden tag sichtbarer
lieferketten brechen zusammen notwendige
rohstoff für vielen und das führt zu
produktionsstopps zur kurzarbeit viele
arbeitsplätze sind bedroht es war
notwendig und richtig dass die
bundesregierung die kurzarbeiterregelung
erweitert das erkennen wir ausdrücklich
an sie haben nachgebessert bei der
zeitarbeit auch bei der möglichkeit die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge wieder zu
ersetzen jetzt
müssen sie dafür sorgen dass die
unternehmen möglichst eine
planungssicherheit in diesen bereichen
tatsächlich auch haben das tut not die
kurzarbeit ist ein gutes ein schnell
wirksames und wir haben das auch in der
pandemie gesehen auch ein teures
instrument das wissen wir und die
kurzarbeit alleine wird nicht ausreichen
um arbeitsplätze zu schützen wir
brauchen passgenaue lösungen gerade für
unsere energieintensiven betriebe die ja
zum teil schon ihre produktion
eingestellt haben und das was die ampel
hier beschlossen hat hilft nicht weiter
mit dem energie gelbe der einmal zahl
mit der kraftstoffsteuer all das hilft
dem produzierenden gewerbe nicht es ist
zu wenig und ist es zu kurz wir brauchen
eine echte entlastung der wirtschaft ein
hilfspaket das auch überbrückungshilfen
umfassen muss hier muss die
bundesregierung das richtige und
notwendige tun und zwar jetzt in diesem
bereich
die wirtschaft unsere arbeitsplätze
brauchen unterstützung auch die menschen
glauben ist millionen sind aufs auto
angewiesen um zur arbeit zu kommen um
einzukaufen um das familienleben zu
organisieren damit die kinder oma und
opa besuchen können oder dass sie am
vereinsleben wieder teilhaben können wir
brauchen ja eine starke soziale
abfederung der krise und die
beschlossenen maßnahmen der ampel helfen
an dieser stelle ja sie reichen jedoch
nicht aus und ist ja interessant wenn
man mal im vorfeld ging ja auch durch
die presse man sieht wie das
bundesarbeitsministerium offenbar
kraftstoff rabatte oder die abschläge
auf die energie steuer bewertet
wird dann typischerweise gesagt
diejenigen mit höherem einkommen die
sind auch mehr mobil und unterwegs aber
erstaunlich ist ja vor allem dass man
dann ratschläge gibt beispielsweise wenn
man so etwas macht bei den steuern diese
runter setzt das gebe kein anreiz zum
sparen steht da obwohl solche auch
kurzfristig umsetzbar wären und dann
gibt es gleich ein rad hinterher man
könnte ja statt 110 km/h 90 km h fahren
jetzt bin ich im ländlichen raum
unterwegs auf landstraßen auf
bundesstraßen muss kann das wir 110
fährt also jedenfalls das zeigt wir
brauchen keine verhaltens ratschläge aus
dem aus des bundesarbeitsministeriums
sondern wir brauchen tragfähige
vorschläge
und diese haben wir unser breites und
spürbare steuersenkungen bei der
energiekosten das natürlich auch die
mehrwertsteuer umfassen muss drei monate
ist viel zu kurz auch gesprungen das was
sie jetzt beschlossen aber natürlich ist
es notwendig die pendlerpauschale zu
erhöhen auch ab dem ersten kilometer
entlasten sie die bürgerinnen und bürger
helfen sie den bürgerinnen und bürger in
dieser schweren situation das ist das
was jetzt not damit wir hier gut durch
diese krisensituation kommen dafür steht
die union
[Musik]
nächster redner für die fraktion bündnis
90 die grünen andreas andreades
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen gestern
haben wir uns als ampel auf das zweite
große entlastungspaket in nur wenigen
wochen verständigt und lieber herr
strecke vielleicht konzentrieren sich
einmal auf das was wir hier debattieren
natürlich ist nicht jede einzelne punkt
in diesem entlastungspaket auch mein
persönlicher favorit ich persönlich
hätte die spritpreis bremse zum beispiel
nicht in der form umgesetzt ich hätte
gerne das geld genommen die an kleine
einkommen gegeben ich hätte gerne das
geld genommen um es an menschen in der
grundsicherung zu geben für die die es
tatsächlich brauchen dann statt das ein
großer einkommen die beim tanken dann
auch noch davon profitieren zu bekommen
aber aber darf ich ihnen das einmal
sagen es geht hier um was anderes in
einer solchen situation in einer solchen
krise in der wir uns gerade befinden
da kommt es darauf an am ende
kompromisse zu finden da kommt es am
ende darauf an dass man verantwortung
übernimmt und ich bin heute ich freue
mich sehr darüber und bin froh darüber
dass wir das als ampel genauso geschafft
haben und dass wir gemeinsam auch dieses
zweite entlastungs paket verabschiedet
haben und dass wir das jetzt gemeinsam
umsetzen
100 euro für menschen in der
grundsicherung wegen drohender 100 euro
für menschen in der grundsicherung
wegen der ukraine krise und der kosten
noch mal 100 euro für jedes kind gerade
auch für kinder in der grundsicherung
und darauf werden wir achten bei der
umsetzung weitere 20 euro und dann im
weiteren verlauf an kinder in armut 270
euro heizkostenzuschuss und nochmal 3
euro energiepreis pauschale für
erwerbstätige das ist die gezielte
unterstützung das ist das was ankommt
und das ist das was wir jetzt genau in
diesem moment brauchen und hinzu kommt
und das ist mir wichtig hinzu kommt wir
schaffen damit den konkreten einstieg in
ein energie geld das konzept wird jetzt
aufgearbeitet das konzept wird im
nächsten jahr umgesetzt und genau daran
zeigen wir dass bei uns energieeffizienz
die frage dass der energie entlastung
die frage der entlastung der kleinen
einkommen und all das zusammen gehörten
das schafft diese ampel hier mit diesen
beiden entlastungspaket und das ist
hervorragend so
unsere solidarität in diesen
krisenzeiten die muss auch denen
menschen gelten die jetzt zu uns kommen
die wegen des kriegs in der ukraine zu
uns kommen wir werden diesen menschen
schutz bieten jeder und jedem einzelnen
wir werden denen eine unterkunft bieten
und wir werden ihnen alles bieten was zu
einem würdigen leben dazugehört und noch
mehr wenn sie das möchten werden wir in
eine perspektive bieten und eine neue
heimat hier bei uns und an dieser stelle
ist es wichtig dass wir jetzt am anfang
investieren dass wir ausreichend mittel
für sprachkurse zur verfügung stellen
und dann wird es gut für alle seiten
denn wir brauchen diese menschen wir
brauchen diese talente diese menschen
können teil unserer gesellschaft sein
die können hier waren sie nicht viel
leisten und ich sage ihnen wenn wir
jetzt investieren
dann wird sich das für alle und für uns
hier in deutschland in einigen jahren
zehn mal auszahlen deswegen sollten wir
genau das jetzt in diesem haushalt tun
gutes putins angriffskrieg die
steigenden preise die vielen
geflüchteten all diese aufgaben all
diese krisen passieren vor dem
hintergrund dass wir immer noch mit den
sozialen fragen und den sozialen
problemen der korona krise kämpfen das
kurzarbeitergeld hat in den vergangenen
jahren massenhaft entlassungen
verhindert in der spitze und das muss
man sich auf der zunge zergehen lassen
die diese zahl in der spitze waren über
sechs millionen menschen in kurzarbeit
die bundesagentur für arbeit hat an
dieser stelle enormes geleistet
ich finde dass es einen moment in dem
man auch mal sagen kann danke an die
sachbearbeiterinnen und sachbearbeiter
an die tausenden von leuten dpa
zusammengezogen wurden um dieses geld
schnell und unkompliziert auszuzahlen
ohne all dieses engagement während wir
nie so gut durch die krise gekommen
wir sehen aber gleichzeitig dass die
krise nicht zu ende sind und dass wir in
einer großen phase der unsicherheit
jetzt über diesen haushalt debattieren
deswegen ist es gut dass eine ergänzung
zu halten wird und angesichts der großen
aufgaben bei geflüchteten bei der
entlastung von menschen bei der weiteren
finanzierung der pa und der kurzarbeit
müssen diese ganzen fragen im ergänzungs
haushalt anständig berücksichtigt werden
das werden wir als ampel umsetzen und
das es wichtig dass es in diesem
ergänzungs haushalt dann nochmal beruft
sich die band findet
wir kämpfen mit krisen wir kämpfen mit
großen krisen ich habe das gerade
beschrieben aber eines darf in dieser
phase nicht in vergessenheit geraten wir
dürfen nicht den blick für die zukunft
verlieren die klimakrise die klimakrise
und ich sage ihnen was das bedeutet die
klimakrise warten nicht und wenn wir
nicht aufpassen wenn wir jetzt nicht
handeln dann wird diese klimakrise bald
zu einer klimakatastrophe werden heute
gehen tausende menschen tausende junge
leute in ganz deutschland in ganz in der
ganzen welt auf die straße um für ein
anderes wirtschaften ein fossil freies
wirtschaften einzutreten sie tun das mit
recht wir müssen darauf antworten und
das bedeutet auch dass wir den
arbeitsmarkt transform informieren schon
jetzt suchen so viele unternehmen nach
nachhaltigen lieferketten nach
klimaneutrale produktion und das muss
man mit großer ehrlichkeit angehen das
wird dazu führen dass nicht jeder job
dass nicht jeder produktionszweig diese
umstellung überleben wird ja das ist
korrekt die produktion von
verbrennungsmotoren für die masse hat
keine zukunft da werden wir wegkommen
müssen aber viele neue jobs viele grüne
jobs nachhaltige jobs entstehen menschen
werden gebraucht an andere stelle sie
werden in der elektrotechnik gebraucht
wir werden in digitalen
produktionsprozessen gebraucht sie
werden bei tesla in grünheide gebraucht
bei bmw in berlin und in münchen sie
werden in hannover bei vw gebraucht und
genauso die ganz in den ganzen
zulieferbetrieben wir grüne und wir als
ampel wir treiben diesen digitalen
transformationsprozess diesen
klimaneutralen transformationsprozess
voran so dass gute chancen dass gute
chancen für alle menschen daraus
entsteht und das ist das was fortschritt
ausmacht das ist das was diese koalition
tut und genau deswegen ist es auch an
der stelle wichtig dass wir die
bundesagentur für arbeit jetzt nicht mit
schulden zurück lassen denn sie wird
gebraucht als zentraler transformations-
akteur für die zukunft sie muss sich
darauf konzentrieren können dass die
pionierinnen und pioniere die sich jetzt
auf den weg machen die jetzt sagen wir
gehen in diese neue zeit des
wirtschaftens sind diese neue zeit des
wohlstandes dass diese menschen jetzt
die begleitung finden deswegen werden
wir die bundestag bundesagentur für
arbeit nicht mit schulden zurück lassen
sondern anständig ausstatten um diese
aufgaben der zukunft auch wahrzunehmen
ein letzte hund die umbrüche und die
chancen die umbrüche die wir haben
müssen auch in unseren anderen projekten
dazu führen dass wir die chancen in den
mittelpunkt stellen das gilt auch wenn
wir endlich uns daran machen das system
hartz 4 zu überwinden teil davon ist
dass teilhabechancen gesetz zu
entfristen damit wir
langzeitarbeitslosen neue wege in die
gesellschaft und in arbeit bieten das
geht aber nur wenn wir auch dafür
ausreichend geld zur verfügung stellen
und auch das werden wir machen machen
dieser haushalt dieses dieser haushalt
ist der erste der ampel koalition lieber
herr minister heilig findet er kann sich
sehen lassen ich finde das eine
anständige haushalt ich freue mich auf
die weiteren beratungen wir werden ihn
besser machen hier im parlament und zwar
gemeinsam mit fdp als bündnis 90/die
grünen und als sozialdemokratische
partei vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächste rednerin für die fdp fraktion
ulrike schielke ziesing
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr minister heil meine damen
und herren die ampel ist mit großen
versprechungen angetreten zur
finanzierung der hehren ziele von
klimarettung gleichstellung und
migrationspolitik sollten sämtliche
ausgaben auf den prüfstand von
priorisierung war im koalitionsvertrag
die rede was damit gemeint ist das sehen
wir heute mehr geld fürs klima weniger
für die menschen schon im ersten entwurf
des bundeshaushaltes sollte am etat für
arbeit und soziales gespart werden und
nun im vorliegenden zweiten entwurf wird
noch weiter gekürzt konkret heißt das
2,8 milliarden weniger will der staat
für sozialleistungen ausgeben davon
alleine 1,8 milliarden weniger vorangeht
2 empfänger ich frage mich was sie zu
diesem optimismus verleitet dass wir in
zukunft weniger bedarf an sozialen
hilfen haben werden zwei jahre corona
misswirtschaft hat schon heute viele
betriebe und wirtschaftliche existenz
gekostet viele hängen am tropf des
kurzarbeitergeldes nun kommt der krieg
in der ukraine dazu schon nach einem
monat sehen wir welch verheerende
auswirkungen die engpässe beim benzin
und energie auf liefer und
produktionskette haben die ersten
speditionen haben bereits aufgegeben
viele betriebe werden das nicht
überleben wir alle wissen die rezession
wird kommen und der bedarf an
sozialleistungen wird steigen nicht
sinken das bestätigt auch das ifo
institut das mit weniger wachstum
rechnet und hohen inflationsraten zudem
mit einer deutlichen zunahme von
kurzarbeit wie solide ist eine
haushaltsplanung die das nicht
berücksichtigt
finanzminister lindner hat ja
angekündigt wegen der krise einen
ergänzungs haushalt einzubringen
das werden wir dann sicher eine erhöhung
dieser haushaltsposition wiederfinden
aber das ist dann doch augenwischerei in
diesem haushaltsentwurf zu sparen in der
gewissheit die fehlenden gelder an
anderer stelle wieder einzubringen der
bundesrechnungshof sagt der
bundeshaushalt muss muss robust
resilient und nachhaltig gestaltet
werden man könnte ergänzen auch mit
ehrlichkeit im aktuellen entwurf für der
bundesagentur für arbeit ein darlehen in
höhe von einer milliarde euro eingeräumt
im ersten entwurf war noch von einem
zuschuss die rede aber wir wissen doch
schon heute das wird nicht reichen denn
dpa hat bekanntlich keine rücklagen mehr
und wir werden in zukunft mit mehr statt
mit weniger kurzarbeit rechnen müssen
wohl gemerkt dass alles bei möglichst
gleichbleibender beiträgen am ende heißt
dass aus den krediten werden dann doch
zuschüsse das sollte man dann auch so
benennen wesentlich bedenklicher ist
aber folgendes die bundesregierung hat
2018 per gesetz beschlossen in den
jahren 22 bis 25
sonderzahlungen von zunächst 500
millionen euro jährlich an die
allgemeine rentenversicherung als
finanzierungs sockel zu überweisen im
ersten regierungsentwurf der alten
regierung finden wir diese zahlen auch
im aktuellen regierungsentwurf sind sie
verschwunden
die begründung aus der kabinettsvorlage
ist abenteuerlich dort heißt es ich
zitiere laute aktuellen renten schätzung
wird die beitragssatz obergrenze nach §
287 absatz 1 sgb 6 bis zum jahre 25
nicht überschritten damit entfällt die
notwendigkeit der sonderzahlungen des
bundes an die allgemeine
rentenversicherung merck 287 ksg bis 6
um das jetzt auch gesetzlich zu stützen
wurde im referentenentwurf von mittwoch
dann mal eben der § 287 aufgehoben also
ein generelles wegfallen des zuschusses
ab 23 und im bundeshaushalts gesetz
schuss zu schuss für 22 gestrichen so
schnell geht das wenn wille und geld
nicht da sind dass es keine
zukunftsorientierte rentenpolitik das
ist politik nach kassenlage wie in einer
bananenrepublik
herr minister weil sie haben vor drei
jahren gesagt die rente ist ein
kernversprechen des sozialstaates aber
was ist aus diesem versprechen geworden
keine einigung der ampel auf eine
rentenreform
kein sparen für die zu erwartende
rentenlücke ab 2025 das ist keine
vorausschauende planung sie fahren auf
sicht
daher für neue maßnahmen die im
koalitionsvertrag angekündigt waren
finden sich in diesem entwurf überhaupt
nicht andere wichtige maßnahmen wurden
gekürzt beispielsweise beim form zur
abmilderung wurden härtefällen in der
rentenüberleitung nach vielen jahren des
wartens fanden sich im ersten entwurf
der alten regierung endlich eine
milliarde euro zum aufbau dieses forums
im zweiten entwurf wurde der betrag auf
500 millionen euro gekürzt diese 500
millionen euro sind ein tropfen auf den
heißen stein und werden nicht einmal
ansatzweise ausreichend
beispielsweise beim vorhaben aus dem
koalitionsvertrag die rentenversicherung
mit einem kapitalstock von zehn
milliarden euro auszustatten darauf
warten wir alle schon bewährten wir alle
noch lange warten müssen der nicht
einmal 500 millionen
zugesagte zahlungen an die
rentenversicherung geleistet werden
können insgesamt ist der haushalt zu
diesen einzelplan enttäuschen ich stelle
fest die kürzungsvorgaben sind zu groß
und die prioritäten der regierung falsch
ich habe deshalb wenig hoffnung dass
hier in den haushaltsberatungen noch
entscheidend nachgebessert werden kann
ich bedanke mich
[Applaus]
nächste rednerin für die fdp fraktion
claudia raffelhüschen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin lieber
minister heil liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
heute geht es um den größten etat im
bundeshaushalt den einzelplan elf also
um arbeit und soziales kein einzelplan
ist so relevanz für fiskalische
nachhaltigkeit
und generationengerechtigkeit die mir
persönlich am herzen liegt der
einzelplan 11 ist für das laufende jahr
in einen haushalte eingebettet der
zwischen der krone pandemie und dem
ukraine krieg kräftig durchgeschüttelt
worden ist ich rede von einem haushalt
jetzt mehr als der hälfte aus
sozialausgaben einschließlich der
zuweisungen an die rentenkasse besteht
ein drittel unserer gesamten
wertschöpfung wird also umverteilt und
damit liegen wir weltweit mit an der
spitze wie soll ich sagen
glücklicherweise verfügen wir über die
höchste steuerquote am
bruttoinlandsprodukt in unserer
geschichte mehr geld wurde den menschen
hierzulande noch nie über steuern und
beiträge entzogen und trotz relativ zur
wirtschaftsleistung
höchsten steuereinnahmen sind wir in
dieser sondersituation leider gezwungen
eine neue
hohe neuverschuldung einzugehen dabei
darf es auf dauer natürlich nicht
bleiben zumal
zumal die ganze last der schulden
unserer zumal wir die ganze last der
schulden unseren kindern aufbürden
lassen sie uns also gemeinsam so schnell
wie möglich in einer nachhaltigeren
haushaltspolitik arbeiten denn wir
können nicht deutlich mehr in
verteidigung infrastruktur und
energiewende investieren ohne in allen
haushaltstiteln die budget ansätze so zu
gestalten dass wir mit weniger mitteln
bessere ergebnisse erzielen
auch und gerade der einzelplan 11 ist
weiterhin geprägt von großen
herausforderungen die durch die kapo
corona pandemie ausgelöst wurden der
staat hat in den vergangenen monaten an
wichtigen stellschrauben gedreht um
bürgerinnen und bürger unternehmerinnen
und unternehmer zu entlasten das war
wichtig das war richtig und trotzdem
dürfen all diese sonderregeln nicht zu
automatismen werden denn was vor kokona
nicht klug war das wird durch die
veränderte lage nicht intelligenter
beispielsweise war der vereinfachte
zugang zum kurzarbeitergeld während der
krise essentiell hat viele unternehmen
vor der insolvenz bewahrt und
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern ein
adäquates einkommen gesichert
insbesondere in zeiten der
wirtschaftlichen erholung müssen wir
aber jetzt den sinn und zweck solcher
sonderregelung evaluieren die gute
nachricht zuletzt entwickelte sich der
arbeitsmarkt wieder
erfolgsversprechend die arbeitslosigkeit
und unterbeschäftigung sind im vergleich
zu den vergangenen pandemien monat
besungen die nachfrage nach mitarbeitern
bewegt sich weiterhin auf hohem niveau
nichtsdestotrotz wirken sich
lieferengpässe und die großen
unsicherheiten durch den russischen
angriff auf die ukraine mit noch nicht
absehbaren folgen auf unseren
arbeitsmarkt und die sozialpolitik aus
deutschland hat es in den vergangenen
jahren leider versäumt eine geregelte
einwanderung in den arbeitsmarkt zu
ermöglichen aus arbeitsmarkt und
sozialpolitischer sicht brauchen wir
diese fachkräfte um die rente die mit
über 100 millionen euro pro jahr durch
den bund bezuschusst wird zu
stabilisieren und das ist sozialsystem
zu entlasten
eigentlich ist dies seit dem pillenknick
hinlänglich bekannt also seit
jahrzehnten bruder aber erfolgreich
ignoriert jetzt geht es hier
nachzubessern
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der punkt investiert in den sozialstaat
und dieser wächst enorm lassen wir uns
aber nicht täuschen denn so schön der
steigende etat auch klingt und so viel
gutes mit dem geld bewirkt werden soll
umso anfälliger wird das gesamtsystem
wenn wir nicht strukturell nachbessern
insbesondere den großen blöcken
arbeitsmarkt und rente besteht
reformbedarf das im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbarte bürgergeld wird erster
bürokratische entlastung für bürger und
auch die verwaltung bringen den
kolleginnen
gestatten sie eine zwischenfrage oder
bemerkungen aus der cdu/csu-fraktion
nein den allerbesten reformbedarf gibt
es allerdings bei der rente bevor
2025 die sogenannte doppelte haltelinie
ausläuft brauchen wir kluge lösung um da
wären wir wieder bei meinen kindern und
den zukünftigen generationen auch ihnen
eine angemessene zukunft zu sichern
denn das wurde seit jahren versprochen
und das höchste gut eines politischen
lebens ist doch die glaubwürdigkeit
vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächste rednerin für die fraktion die
linke dr gesine lötzsch
vielen dank frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren auch heute
morgen muss ich meine rede mit der
forderung beginnen putin muss die
russische armee aus der ukraine abziehen
den krieg beenden die menschen in der
ukraine und überall in der welt haben
das recht in frieden zu leben
und
ich finde es falsch dass in dieser
situation die ausgaben für arbeit und
soziales gekürzt werden der rüstungsetat
wird erhöht das hat allerdings nichts
mit dem krieg in der ukraine zu tun das
war lange vorbereitet meine damen und
herren die bundesregierung geht mit
diesem haushaltsentwurf für den
einzelplan elf von sinkenden
arbeitslosenzahlen aus aber in
anbetracht einer globalen
wirtschaftskrise in anbetracht von
kriegen und ihren folgen ist das doch
mehr als fraglich
hier muss also vorgesorgt werden und
nicht gestrichen meine damen und herren
diese kreis explosion bei energie und
lebensmitteln
bedrohend viele menschen besonders die
die wenig geld haben deshalb fordern wir
den mindestlohn nicht erst zum ersten
oktober 2022 auf 12 euro zu erhöhen
sondern bereits zum ersten mal die
menschen brauchen das geld sofort
ich weiß die ehrung des mindestlohnes
ist für die fdp kein thema sie fühlt
sich er zuständig für die verwaltung der
vermögen der superreichen
doch von spd und grünen erwarte ich dass
sie ein zeichen setzen zwölf euro pro
stunde am tag der arbeit dass wir ein
gutes zeichen
den razzien satz haben sie im ganzen
drei euro an drogen es ist beschämend
wie sie mit den arbeitslosen umgehen für
stromkosten bekommen aktuell arbeitslose
eine pauschale von 36 euro pro monat
aber derzeit zeit man fast das doppelte
weil man einen neuvertrag beim
günstigsten anbieter abschließen meine
damen und herren der paritätische
wohlfahrtsverband fordert einen
hartz-iv-satz von 678 euro pro monat
diese forderung unterstützen wir
die renten steigen im augenblick doch
von der erhöhung wird nicht viel übrig
bleiben die inflation frisst die
rentenerhöhung auf und wir wiederholen
unsere forderung die ost renten müssen
endlich angepasst werden das betrifft
nicht nur die heutigen rentner sondern
auch künftige und das ist nötig
einnahmen die rente muss auch ein thema
für die jugend werden die
bundesregierung will die rente den
risiken des kapitalmarktes aussetzen
aber wir wollen keine pensionsfonds die
in krieg kohle und atomkraft investieren
generationengerechtigkeit heißt auch
dass die heutige jugend im alter eine
gute und saubere rente halten kann
schildern
nächste rednerin für die spd-fraktion
kattrin michel
frau präsidentin lieber minister hahn
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen jesse
linie markiert
seit dienstag beschäftigen wir uns hier
parlament mit dem haushaltsentwurf in
all seinen facetten
wir haben viel reden gehört reden über
einen haushalt in herausfordernden
zeiten doch eins kam ja oft und sehr
selten zu tage
in diese reden habe ich vermisst dass
angesichts der aktuellen lage und
vielfältigen herausforderungen denen wir
uns stellen müssen für besonders wichtig
ja entscheidend achte das übernehmen von
verantwortung
verantwortung für kommendes
verantwortung dafür in zeiten wie diesen
ein haushalt aufzustellen der gerecht
und gleichermaßen auskömmlich ist denn
wir stehen vor einer entscheidenden
zeitenwende sicherheits und
energiepolitisch wirtschaftlich wie auch
gesellschaftlich es sozial gerecht zu
gestalten alle mitzunehmen das muss doch
unser anspruch sein
jetzt ist nicht die zeit für
rückwärtsgewandte schuldzuweisung und
drohgebärden jetzt ist zeit für kluge
entscheidung für konstruktive
zusammenarbeit dass es zeit für
fraktionsübergreifend aber jetzt ist
zeit dafür die zeitenwende finanziell
und sozial sicher zu gestalten
und jetzt ist zeit dafür verantwortung
zu übernehmen und genau dafür steht die
ampel koalition mit unserem
bundeskanzler olaf scholz an ihrer
spitze
im einzelplan 11 dass wir mal es sind
ausgaben von über 160 milliarden euro
vorgesehen 160 milliarden euro für
unseren sozialstaat
160 milliarden euro für die
existenzielle sicherheit eines jeden
einzelnen und 160 milliarden euro für
den sozialen frieden in deutschland
eine globalisierte sich schnell
ändernden arbeitswelt sich zusätzlich
dem demografischen wandel und der
digitalisierung zu stellen hat verlangt
immer wieder nach neuen antworten und
dachten wir zu anfang die bewältigung
der gofit 19 pandemie wäre unsere größte
herausforderung in diesen zeiten weit
gefehlt liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
putin führt einen verabscheuungswürdigen
angriffskrieg in der ukraine und hat
sich schuldig gemacht dass millionen von
ukrainerin aus ihrer heimat flüchten
müssen sie flüchten denn ihre
nachbarländer aber auch zu tausenden
nach deutschland es liegt doch jetzt in
unserer verantwortung auch diesen
menschen in deutschland sicherheit zu
gewährleisten und über den moment hinaus
gedacht in die chance für einen
neuanfang zu bieten wir gehen davon aus
dass viele der ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer hier in deutschland arbeiten
wollen es sind überwiegend frauen die zu
uns kommen gut ausgebildet mit
fachschulabschluss und um
sicherzustellen dass sie geben nicht auf
helfertätigkeiten ausweichen müssen
sondern ihre ausbildung entsprechend
eingesetzt werden können es die
berufsbezogene deutsch sprach forderung
zwingend notwendig
und bereits jetzt ist absehbar dass die
bergsport nicht hinlänglich finanziert
sein wird und darum müssen wir
gewährleisten dass die entsprechenden
mittel zur verfügung gestellt werden
grundlage des entwurfs prognosen die
eine erholung des arbeitsmarktes nach
profit 19 voraussagten nun der krieg
lässt unsere lieferketten stocken
energiepreise in die höhe schnellen und
wieder sind arbeitsplätze in gefahr und
darum ist es für unsere volkswirtschaft
existenziell dass wir das
kurzarbeitergeld weiter als stabile
brücke vorhalten es ist das wirksamste
mittel menschen in arbeit zu halten und
entlassungen vorzubeugen wir haben mit
einem ausgewogenen einzelplan
sicherzustellen dass das thema es weiter
so sicher und zuverlässig sein
zahlreichen aufgaben nachgehen kann und
dazu gehört dass mittels energie zierten
arbeitsmarkt und sozialpolitik
entsprechend zu reagieren aber auch im
besonderen vorausschauend agieren zu
können ziel dabei ist es dass so viele
menschen wie möglich eine
erwerbstätigkeit nachgehen können wir
finanzieren arbeit statt
arbeitslosigkeit wir wollen
mitbestimmung das pack und sicherheit
und das gilt selbstverständlich auch so
die menschen die neu zu uns kommen sie
alle brauchen zur teilhabe eine
perspektive eine verlässliche
unterstützung und dafür müssen wir
entsprechende beratungsangebote ausbauen
der sozialstaat muss vor lebensrisiken
schützen und verlässlich bleiben und
damit der sozialstaat leistungsfähig und
verlässlich bleibt müssen wir die
nötigen mittel klug und nachhaltig
einsetzen einsparen um des sparens
willen wäre fatal und verantwortungslos
wir als diese stellen ganz klar die
menschen in den mittelpunkt der sache
das was sie für eine gute arbeit und
eine auskömmliche soziale sicherung in
verschiedenen phasen des lebens
benötigen stellen wir ihn zur verfügung
die bundesagentur für arbeit ist das
zentrale organ für den sozialen
arbeitsmarkt in zeiten der pandemie hat
die bundesagentur mit dem instrument der
kurzarbeit eine brücke gebaut so dass
arbeitsplätze erhalten werden konnten
und die volkswirtschaft nicht größeren
schaden genommen hat nun für putin krieg
und die aktuellsten prognosen zeigen
heute das eine verdoppelung der
ursprünglich erwarteten bezieherinnen
von kurzarbeitergeld mehr als
wahrscheinlich ist eine verdopplung
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das im
vorliegenden entwurf des einzelplan 11
angedachte darlehen für die
bundesagentur für arbeit ist nicht das
geeignete mittel dabei es führt in gänze
zu einer schwäche der handlungs
wirksamkeit wir benötigen jetzt eine
starke agentur die jederzeit in der lage
ist angemessen und flexibel auf die sich
abzeichnenden herausforderungen zu
reagieren
eine agentur ohne schulden
helmut schmidt sagt richtig in der krise
zeigt sich der charakter und wir stehen
für den sozialen zusammenhalt und ein
solidarisches miteinander
diese aufgabe steht im mittelpunkt
dieses haushalts das ist unsere
verantwortung das ist sicherheit im
wandel ich freue mich auf erfolgreiche
beratungen vielen dank und glückauf
[Applaus]
bevor ich dem nächsten redner aufrufe
noch mal einen hinweis an die kollegin
frau von storch sie hatten vorhin
die ganze zeit wieder die maske leider
unter der nase ich würde sie bitten auch
wenn es schwer fällt das handy manchmal
mit maske zu entsperren
weil wir gestern im ältestenrat auch
nochmal ausführlich darüber gesprochen
haben noch haben wir hier die masken
pflicht und ich bitte sie die maske
richtig aufzusetzen ja jetzt aber sie an
während ich habe drei minuten mindestens
ich habe
das kann ich nicht während einer rede
will ich die rede nicht unterbrechen
deswegen tue ich das jetzt sonst hätte
ich das sicherlich sofort gemacht aber
ich will und möchte auch die rednerinnen
und redner nicht immer deswegen
unterbrechen es ist nur noch mal ein
zarter hinweis ich bitte einfach nur
darum
dass wir uns alle daran halten so lange
es diese masten pflicht noch gibt hier
im saal vielen dank
der nächste redner ist jetzt für die cdu
csu fraktion peter aumer
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wenn wir über
den haushalt arbeit und soziales reden
können wir zu beginn drei dinge
feststellen erstens unsere deutsche
wirtschaft und der arbeitsmarkt sind
stabil zweitens unser sozialstaat
funktioniert und ist leistungsfähig und
drittens es muss ich aber einiges ändern
dass das auch in zukunft so bleibt
auch diese drei punkte möchte ich meiner
rede kurz eingehen erstens das thema
arbeitsmarkt und wirtschaft sie wurde am
behalten und zwar immer vor was in 16
jahren regierungsverantwortung alles
schief gelaufen sein soll meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren wenn wir über
den haushalt arbeit und soziales
sprechen dann zeigen wir ihnen das
paradebeispiel wie verantwortungsvolle
politik funktioniert an daran der
beschäftigungszuwachs 16 jahre lang 2009
40,9 millionen erwerbstätige 2009/10
45,3 millionen erwerbstätige zahl der
arbeitslosen halbiert seit 2005 ich
denke das ist eine bilanz die sie meine
damen und herren erst mal nachmachen
müssen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der ampel
arbeitsmarkt politik funktioniert vor
allem durch eine aktivierende
arbeitsmarktpolitik
deshalb kann man nur mit dem kopf
schütteln wenn eine ihrer ersten
maßnahmen des aussetzen der sanktionen
in der grundsicherung für arbeitsuchende
es treten sie reden sie herr kollege
burkhardt mal mit der bundesagentur für
arbeit reden sie mit den jobcentern vor
ort vielleicht sollten sie mal öfter im
wahlkreis unterwegs sein dann merken sie
das fordern und fördern für die menschen
ein ganz wesentlicher fokus
verantwortungsvolle
arbeitsmarktpolitik bedeutet vor allem
in krisenzeiten starke zeichen zu setzen
wir haben das in unserer
regierungsverantwortung getan zwei große
rezessionen wir haben gemeinsam mit den
kollegen der spd starke antworten
gegeben die fdp war sogar mit dabei beim
thema kurzarbeitergeld in der
finanzkrise 2008/2009 1.4 millionen in
der finanzkrise 6 millionen menschen im
höhepunkt der kogit 19 pandemie waren in
kurzarbeit und ich denke dass auch so
ein signal gesetzt wird wie
verantwortungsvolle politik gemacht wird
und der mann heute auf sie schaut liebe
kollegen der ampel
regierungshandeln wäre gefragt in einer
großen weiteren krise von der wir in
europa stehen und auf der welt die
ukraine krise steigende energiepreise
hohe inflation kraftvolles handeln der
ampelkoalition fehlanzeige liebe
kollegen ende februar erstes
entlastungspaket angekündigt 13
milliarden euro nicht mal einen monat
später braucht es zweite
entlastungspaket weil nicht aus einem
guss
nicht überlegt nicht nachgedacht meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren so
funktioniert verantwortungsvolle politik
nicht und wenn man dann genauer schaut
ist es keine
sozialpolitik aus einem guss sondern
herr heil auch wenn sie es anders
dargestellt haben sozialpolitik mit
gießkanne und dass meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren ist nicht die antwort
die wir in dieser zeit brauchen das
kritisieren alle sozialverbände
angefangen vom vdk sie sagen die
rentnerinnen und rentner wurden
vergessen von der diakonie vom
bayerischen caritasverband die sagen
dass das alles sozial nicht ausgewogen
ist und dass meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren ist auch denke ich auftrag
für simon klein bisschen genauer zu
schauen vor allem wenn man immer sehr
großes thema respekt in den letzten
wochen und monaten gespielt hat zu und
einen funktionierenden sozialstaat
gehört auch respekt vor leistung und
dass meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren es in einer zeit wie diesen und
bei den entlastungs paket ebenfalls
wichtig weil meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren das geld das wir hier heute
ausgeben muss auch irgendjemand
erwirtschaften und verdienen deswegen hh
wir wissen dass sie wahrscheinlich nicht
kleine entlastungs paketen kein einziges
mal entlastungen für die wirtschaft
auftauchen dort wo arbeitsplätze
entstehen gesichert werden gerade im
energieintensiven bereichen sie total
vergessen deswegen bin ich ganz feste
überzeugung dass das nächste
entlastungspaket drei wahrscheinlich
auch ganz schnell folgen werden muss
dass wir hier schwerere folgen und einen
schweren schaden für unser land auch
vermeiden können meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren der fortschritts
koalition fortschritt schaut anders aus
für uns ist wichtig gerade in dieser
zeit dass wir auch weichen neu stellen
dass wir darüber nachdenken wie
funktioniert der arbeitsmarkt der
zukunft wie funktioniert der sozialstaat
und die sozialsysteme der zukunft das ja
auch weiterhin leistungsfähig sind wenn
man genauer in den haushalt schaut wird
deutlich dass sie keine neuen impulse
setzen beispielsweise beim
haushaltstitel arbeitswelt im wandel und
fachkräftesicherung unsere wirtschaft
braucht dringend neue impulse
raffelhüschen hat es vor in ihrer rede
ja gesagt impulse fehlen aber in diesem
haushalt bei diesem wichtigen thema in
einer wirtschaft die nicht nur
fachkräftemangel mittlerweile hat
sondern auch arbeitskräftemangel und
auch beim thema soziale sicherheit
müssen wir die weichen stark stellen bei
der rente müssen wir endlich wegkommen
von den grundsatzdebatten und antworten
finden
antworten antworten herr kollege rose
waren die wir erarbeitet haben in der
letzten legislaturperiode in einer
großen kommission diese punkte müssen
wir endlich in umsetzung bringen und
dazu haben wir die zusammenarbeit auch
als union angeboten weil uns wichtig ist
ein system zukunftsfest zu machen auch
dass viele menschen in unserem land
vertrauen seit jahrzehnten und deswegen
müssen wir da auch eine starke antwort
finden die hand ist ausgestreckt und ich
glaube hier müssen wir gemeinsam den
menschen in unserem land eine antwort
geben und die antworten die der
politisch motiviert in vielerlei
bereichen sind merken wir ja bei der fdp
die mit die zehn milliarden
fehlen irgendwie in diesem haushalt wir
wissen wenn man kapitalgedecktes system
da müssen wir schnell anfangen ja mal
gespannt wie lange wir brauchen müssen
wir das system dann auch einführen meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren
sozialpolitik arbeitsmarktpolitik
braucht starke impulse den nächsten
jahren wir als union sind dabei diese
impulse mit zusätzen herzlichen dank für
die
nächster redner für die fraktion bündnis
90 die grünen frank system
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren ihnen möchte ich
einfach mal einblick in die dokumente
empfehlen der entlastungspaket manchmal
verschafft die lektüre echten
erkenntnisgewinne
die ökologische transformation
mit einem mehr an sozialer sicherheit
verbinden ist ein zentrales anliegen
grüner politik
dafür haben wir eine
koalitionsvereinbarung wichtige akzente
gesetzt für ein bürgergeld dass das
system überwindet für eine
kindergrundsicherung die der kinderarmut
in unserem land entgegenwirkt und für
eine arbeitsmarktpolitik die den
beschäftigten perspektiven eröffnet das
wollen wir in den kommenden monaten
weiter konkretisieren und das hat aber
auch schon in diesem haushaltsentwurf
seinen niederschlag gefunden ich nenne
beispielhaft den kinder sofort zuschlag
die aufstockung der weiterbildungs
mittel für das programm arbeitswelt im
wandel die verlängerung des
kurzarbeitergeldes oder auch die
fortführung des sozialdienstleister
einsatz gesetzes
weil ich
freilich gibt es punkte wo in den
beratungen zum vorgelegten entwurf nach
zu arbeiten sein wird für das programm
barrierefreiheit müssen zusätzlich
mittel in die finanzplanung eingestellt
werden und auch der einfrierung titel
für den sozialen arbeitsmarkt wird
deutlich angehoben werden müssen der
soziale arbeitsmarkt hat sich bewährt
eine mittelkürzung verbietet sich schon
deshalb weil die zahl der arbeitsplätze
dort nicht verringern wollen
am ersten zehn
greift die anhebung des gesetzlichen
mindestlohns wer den meisten
arbeitsplätzen in diesem bereich zu
grunde liegt benötigt werden mithin mehr
mittel und nicht weniger
damit aber nicht genug
sehen wir uns jetzt doch alle mit den
folgen des russischen angriffskrieges
gegen die ukraine konfrontiert
die wachstumsannahmen dann aktuell nach
unten korrigiert
produktionsausfällen führen zu einem
erneuten anstieg der anzahl der
kurzarbeitenden die integration
hunderttausender gefürchteter in den
arbeitsmarkt und unsere gesellschaft
stellt uns vor große aufgaben
mit einem rückgang der
arbeitslosenzahlen gerechnet werden kann
ist mehr als fraglich und anhaltende
preisanstieg konfrontiert die privaten
haushalte ebenso wie viele unternehmen
mit hohen belastung
neben der einarbeitung des zweiten
entlastungspaket ist der ampel verlangt
dass zwingend eine erweiterung des
haushaltsentwurfs denn im gefolge der
ukraine kriege krisen des ukraine
krieges kommen zusätzliche aufgaben auch
auf die bundesagentur für arbeit zu und
das in einem maße wie es so bis vor
kurzem überhaupt nicht absehbar war
sprachkurse das war bereits angesprochen
werden für die integration der
geflüchteten in den deutschen
arbeitsmarkt erfolgskritisch dafür
müssen zusätzlich mittel bereitgestellt
werden
die wünschenswert überführung flüchteten
aus dem
asylbewerberleistungsgesetz in das sgb 2
wird nicht unerhebliche mittel erfordern
das gleiche gilt für die einbeziehung
der leiharbeit in das verlängerte
kurzarbeitergeld und sie zukommen kann
noch eine rückerstattung von
sozialversicherungsabgaben an die
unternehmen all das
macht es erforderlich auch weiterhin
darlehens beträge an dpa in einen
zuschuss umzuwandeln
keine frage die folgen des ukraine
krieges verlangen nach einer stärkung
des sozialen zusammenhalt in unserem
land dabei stellen sich von neuem auf
fragen der verteilungsgerechtigkeit
in dieser woche ist von verschiedenen
rednerinnen und rednern wiederholt
empörung geäußert worden mit blick auf
das vorgehen der mineralölkonzerne und
das sehr zu recht das sind
kriegsgewinnler
profiteure des krieges konzerne die aus
der not der menschen aus den wirkungen
des krieges extra profite schlagen und
ich frage sie wollen wir die
extraprofite konzerne wirklich unter
welpenschutz stellen und als sechs
prozent hinnehmen wollen wir das
wirklich
wollen wir das glück nicht an der
situation wo wir staatliche
milliardenkredite aufnehmen um den
folgen dieses krieges zu begegnen oder
sollten wir nicht immer das tun was in
der vergangenheit staaten wie die usa
großbritannien frankreich kanada und
anderen kriegs und krisenzeiten immer
wieder getan haben und was jetzt in
dieser woche auch die regierung trage in
italien her angekündigt hat nämlich
mindestens einen teil dieser
extraprofite mittels anderer über gewinn
steuer zugunsten allgemeinheit
abzuschöpfen
abgeordnete
wir sprechen in dieser woche über unsere
finanzplanung und der nächsten
bundeshaushalt da der blick zu weiten
macht sinn es wäre ein signal zugunsten
eines mehr an sozialer gerechtigkeit und
für eine faire verteilung der lasten
nächster redner für die afg fraktionen
robert kleinwächter
[Applaus]
werte frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen jetzt reden wir doch
endlich mal über den elefant im raum und
das ist die inflation
6% erwartet 7 prozent bei den
lebensmitteln 20,8 prozent bei der
energie 30 prozent bei den kraftstoffen
das ist noch nicht das ende der
fahnenstange meine damen und herren die
inflation ist die soziale frage weil sie
uns direkt in die rezession und in
verlust des wohlstands führt und meine
damen und herren
das ist ihre inflation das ist ihre
verantwortung das ist kein ferner putin
und kein ferner konzern hep sie es gibt
sondern dass die europäische zentralbank
die geld druckt ohne ende und es sind
ihre hohe renten steuern mit denen sie
versuchen die leute zu erziehen zu einem
gewissen verhalten sie treiben doch die
preise mit ihrer co2 steuer mit ihren
energiesteuern und ihrer völlig falschen
politik es ist ehre inflation
und das haben sie uns gelacht als wir
forderten den atomausstieg
zurückzunehmen um bezahlbare energie zu
haben oder die energie steuern zu senken
illegale migranten zurückzuweisen damit
der wohnraum nicht exorbitant teuer wird
keine luft zu machen damit die
wirtschaft entsprechend mittel hat oder
eben aus dem euro auszusteigen weil die
ezb geld druckt und politik gegen den
bürger macht meine damen und herren die
geldmenge hat sich seit einführung des
euro fast verdreifacht fragen sie mal
die leute ob sie jetzt drei mal so viel
verdienen
dreimal so viel bezahlen tun sie ganz
sicher und da vergeht ihnen das lachen
wenn sie nicht mehr wissen wie sie für
ihre kinder die kleidung kaufen sollen
wie sie ihre miete bezahlen soll wie sie
noch heizen sollen und was kriegen die
leute dafür sie kriegen hohn und spott
unter anderem von cdu-minister haupt der
forderte 15 grad reichen aus in einer
wohnung
werde mit jeder die regierung es ist
jetzt mehr verantwortung zu haben
aber dieser verantwortung kommen sie
nicht nach auch mit ihrem energiepaket
nicht sie verteilen ein paar almosen 200
euro für die sozialhilfeempfänger 100
für die kinder die steuerpflichtigen
kriegen einen bonus von 300 euro von dem
vielleicht noch 160 übrig bleiben und
bei den renten dann wissen sie noch echt
nicht recht ob sie die einbeziehen
wollen oder nicht vielleicht reichen
daher pullover und eine warme decke
meine damen und herren die afg hat ihnen
schon vor monaten vorschläge
unterbreitet wie diese härten abzufedern
sind neben dem bestehen natürlich auf
geldwertstabilität bei der währung geht
es darum den steuerlichen
grundfreibetrag nicht nur und 300 euro
sondern um knapp 3000 euro zu erhöhen
sind selbstverständlich müssen wir noch
das existenzminimum steuerfrei stellen
wo sind sie denn in diesem land die
regelsätze hartz iv grundsicherung
müssen natürlich angepasst werden der
sparerpauschbetrag sollte erhöht werden
und auch die entfernungspauschale
sollten wir realistisch gestalten mit 38
cent pro kilometer aber das alles machen
sie nicht sie halten fest an co2 steuern
eeg-umlage gebäude energie gesetz all
das müsste ausgesetzt werden auch die
mehrwertsteuer auf energie treibstoff
und lebensmittel für eine zeit um eben
diese folgen der inflation abzumildern
aber nichts davon findet sich im
haushaltsentwurf sie sparen
ausgerechnet bei der integration
schwerbehinderter in den arbeitsmarkt da
gehen sie zurück von 606 auf 519
millionen das ist eine schande für sich
damit sie eineinhalb millionen haben für
die g7 präsidentschaft eineinhalb
millionen für einen freiwilligen beitrag
für die internationale
arbeitsorganisation
für die deutsch sprach förderung und
sieben millionen für ein ganz neues
programm unsere arbeit unsere vielfalt
initiative für betriebliche demokratie
kompetenz da lernt vermutlich dann der
integrationswillige migranten dass die
afg doof und frei ist für future
antirassistisch sei
während die kollegen von der fdp herr
fricke hat uns ja aufgefordert posten zu
lernen wo wir sparen können einsparungen
vornehmen sie sind ja auch da und ich
gebe ihnen mein tipp das sind posten wo
man ausgaben hat aber keine einnahmen
zum beispiel die ganzen europäischen
fonds fwg habt da haben wir 84 millionen
ausgaben im haushalt stehen 09 nahmen
sparen fängt man am besten damit an dass
man nichts sinnlos verschleudert meine
damen und herren
eine zahl gibt mir dennoch nach rätsel
auf in diesem haushalt und das ist
tatsächlich wie sie dazu kommen dass bei
all diesen inflationseffekte armut
arbeitslosigkeit pankow wird lockt da
uns lieferketten probleme ukraine krug
millionen kriegst du nicht länger dass
sie dazu kommen dass sie die den ansatz
für die grundsicherung senken von 45
milliarden auf 40 und für die kosten von
unterkunft und heizung und ich habe mir
dann gedacht haben sich verrechnet kann
eigentlich nicht sein haben sie uns
verladen und bringt das alles aus dem
nachtragshaushalt das wäre ziemlich
wenig lieber fdp von einer service
regierung was ich doch von ihnen
erwartet und dann ist es mir wie
schuppen von den augen gefallen ist kann
ja nur dass sein sicherlich wird nancy
faeser endlich mal die hunderttausenden
illegalen migranten abschieben die bei
uns arten dann stimmen auch die zahlen
in der grundsicherung wieder und ich
danke ihnen werte kollegen der spd und
der grünen dass sie diesen wichtigen
schritt für die bundesrepublik
deutschland mit uns zusammen gehen
werden ich freue mich auf die
parlamentarische begleitung dieses
wichtigen schritt des prozesses haben
sie herzlichen dank
nächster redner für die fdp-fraktion
pascal kober
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der angriff
putins auf die eu keine geht auch nicht
spurlos am politikbereich arbeitsmarkt
und sozialpolitik vorbei
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen es ist
erschütternd mit welcher ruchlosigkeit
mit welcher brutalität
wladimir putin die menschen in der
ukraine
aus ihrer sozialen existenz regelrecht
in die flucht hinauskommt und so werden
die kommenden wochen und monate auch im
bereich arbeitsmarkt und sozialpolitik
wesentlich davon geprägt sein wie wir
die wehrhaftigkeit unser freiheitlich
demokratie wie wir die mehrheit
wehrhaftigkeit eines völkerrechtlich
gebundenen staates einer völkerrechtlich
gebundenen welt auch sozialpolitisch mit
unterstützen damit nach ende putin nicht
recht bekommen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
und zugleich müssen wir mit denken auch
heute schon dass möglicherweise die
menschen die jetzt zu uns kommen über
einen längeren zeitraum bei uns schutz
brauchen und da werden wir dafür sorgen
dass die lebenshaltungskosten
gewährleistet sind das pflege und
betreuung gewährleistet ist für die
menschen die zu uns kommen und der bald
gebrauchen brauchen und vor allen dingen
müssen wir aber auch den arbeitstag
zugang nicht so ermöglichen dass die
menschen möglichst nicht unterhalb ihrer
qualifikation
sondern qualifiziert in unserem
arbeitsmarkt zugang finden
die kollegen belegen die ruchlosigkeit
des russischen präsidenten mag noch so
groß sein aber ich glaube ich spreche
für alle demokratischen fraktionen in
ihrem haus die solidarität unseres
sozialstaates wird stärker sein und
darauf können sich die menschen
verlassen
und dabei ist uns allen natürlich
bewusst dass die auswirkungen des
krieges in der ukraine auch
wirtschaftlicher unsicherheit zu uns
bringen die steigenden energiekosten
möglicherweise auch eines tages aus
fallende energie lieferungen
abbrechenden lieferketten allgemein
steigende preise werden ihre
auswirkungen auf unseren arbeitsmarkt
haben aber auch wenn vieles schwerer
werden wird eine zusage machen wir den
menschen in unserem land wir werden
trotz aller schwierigkeiten die ideen
unseres sitzt unseres
koalitionsvertrages in der arbeitsmarkt
und sozialpolitik umsätzen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
dabei ist uns als fdp insbesondere
zweierlei wichtig das ist die
generationengerechtigkeit auf der einen
seite und das ist die
chancengerechtigkeit auf der anderen
seite und generationengerechtigkeit
bedeutet dass wir zb im bereich der
rentenpolitik nicht nur bis zum ende
dieser legislaturperiode denken sondern
dass wir in generationen denken und das
will das ändern das thema auf
nachhaltige weise reformieren und für
die zukunft aufstellen und dazu gehört
natürlich die aktien rente dazu gehört
ein kapitalgedeckter baustein zur
stabilisierung der rentenversicherung
dazu gehört aber auch die ausweitung der
betrieblichen altersvorsorge und die
flexibilisierung der privaten
altersvorsorge und auch im bereich der
langzeitarbeitslosigkeit werden wir neue
wege gehen den einstieg und den wieder
einstieg in arbeit in dem weg in ein
selbstbestimmtes leben werden wir eben
in dem wir den menschen die hier für
individuell notwendige bildungs und
ausbildungsangebote machen werden das
ist es was unser anspruch ist die
menschen in die arbeit zu bringen
und das fängt natürlich auch bei den
grundkompetenzen an liebe kollegium
kollegen lesen schreiben und rechnen
lernen zu dürfen
auch jenseits des schul alters und auch
wenn man es vielleicht zwei oder drei
mal im leben noch nicht geschafft hat
das ist ein soziales grundrecht das für
jeden in diesem land möglich sein muss
und wir werden den worten kein kind darf
verloren gehen endlich mit
sozialpolitischer substanz begegnen wir
werden diesem versprechen auch wirklich
ein inhalt geben zb mit dem digitalen
kinder chancen portal in dem wir die
angebote in der bildung und teilhabe für
kinder auch wirklich erreichbar und
unkompliziert umsetzbar machen werden
chancengerechtigkeit wird in diesem land
verbessert werden dafür steht diese
regierungskoalition
und wir werden die kooperation der
jobcenter mit der jugendhilfe ausweiten
damit junge menschen auch schon in
frühen jahren früheren jahren als bisher
beim schulerfolg unterstützt werden
können den schulerfolg ist die
vorausbildung für ausbildungserfolg
ausbildungserfolg ist in vielen fällen
die garantie dafür dass
langzeitarbeitslosigkeit verbieten
werden kann und so werden wir den
gedanken des präventiven sozialstaates
mit diesen ganz konkreten maßnahmen
umsetzen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der regierungskoalition ich freue mich
darauf wir haben viel vor wir werden
viel erreichen dieses versprechen geben
wir den menschen in unserem land vielen
dank
[Applaus]
nächste rednerin für die fraktion die
linke so seine fesche
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen herr
minister pandemie klimakrise inflation
krieg alternde wirtschaftskrise dieser
dauer krisen modus verschärft die
soziale ungleichheit im land und
betroffen sind menschen mit niedrigen
einkommen aber auch die mittelschicht
leidet
gleichzeitig bekommt aufrüstung
verfassungsrang 100 milliarden euro als
sondervermögen für rüstung bringen
welche immer also auch diejenigen die
aufstocken müssen und rentner in
grundsicherung sind in echter
finanzieller not und um armut
wirkungsvoll zu bekämpfen sind aus sicht
der linken mindestens drei
sofortmassnahmen nötig und zwar
dauerhaft und nicht nur als
einmalzahlung eine erhöhung der
regelsätze auf deutlich über 600 euro
eine mindestrente von 1200 euro ist und
dass die auffanglinie und
in summe würde das ungefähr 30
milliarden euro kosten nicht mal ein
drittel des über nacht bereitgestellten
sondervermögens und der berater des
finanzministers lars feld der hat
bereits am dienstag gesagt genau das was
sie ausgeschlossen haben herr minister
er hat angekündigt dass zugunsten der
militärischen aufrüstung im sozialen
gespart werden muss und letztlich sieht
man es ja auch schon an der einen oder
anderen stelle die sonderzahlungen des
bundes in die rentenkasse die werden in
diesem jahr nicht geleistet und somit
werden die rücklagen geplündert und
momentan sieht ihr entwurf auch noch vor
dass die bundesagentur zum ausgleich für
defizit eben keinen steuerzuschuss
bekommt sondern einen kredit und ich
fordere sie auf ändern sie das und
schließen sie belastungen für die
beschäftigten aus
kürzungen bei den sozialleistungen sind
nur auf den ersten blick billiger ein
starker sozialstaat ist deutlich mehr
wert als er kostet und deswegen sollten
sie den haushalt nachbessern vielen dank
nächster redner für die spd fraktion dr
martin rosemann
[Applaus]
verehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
fortschritt und sicherheit sind zwei
seiten einer medaille
und gerade veränderungen verlangen
sicherheit
diese regierung diese ampel koalition
hat respekt sozialen fortschritt und
sozialen zusammenhalt versprochen
bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat am
mittwoch ja von diesem pult folgenden
satz gesagt die bürgerinnen und bürger
müssen spüren jede und jeder einzelne
zählt meinen beitrag meine anstrengung
wird wertgeschätzt und diese ampel
koalition hält wort wir werden den
mindestlohn auf 12 euro erhöhen ab dem
ersten oktober
wir sicher wieder kurzarbeit
arbeitsplätze und wir unterstützen
private haushalte bei den gestiegenen
energiepreisen
gerade in zeiten der unsicherheit gilt
äußere sicherheit
innere sicherheit und sozialer
sicherheit gehören zusammen und dürfen
nicht gegeneinander ausgespielt werden
diese krise bewältigen wir nur wenn wir
als gesellschaft solidarisch zusammen
halten deshalb müssen wir weiterhin in
sozialen zusammenhalt investieren wir
müssen sicherstellen dass die hohen
energiepreise nicht von dem kleinen
einkommen bezahlt werden und deswegen
entlastet diese ampel koalition die
bürgerinnen und
die wegen der energiepreise finanziell
überfordert sind gezielt wir haben zwei
entlastungs paket auf den weg gebracht
zwei entlastungspaket und heraus
dazwischen lag immerhin der beginn des
völkerrechtswidrigen russischen
angriffskriegs auf die ukraine das erste
entlastungspaket ist ja noch vor dem
krieg verabschiedet worden und jetzt
haben wir auf die aktuelle situation
nochmal reagiert mit dem zweiten
entlastungspaket also
ich sag immer
heizkostenzuschuss einmalzahlung für
grundsicherungs beziehende beides
verdoppelt energiepreis pauschale und
einmalzahlungen für kinder damit sorgen
wir dafür dass starke schultern nicht
nur mehr leisten können sondern auch
mehr leisten werden als schwache
meine damen und herren
die herausforderungen der transformation
sind aber auch durch den krieg in der
ukraine nicht weg ganz im gegenteil das
muss jetzt alles sogar sehr viel
schneller gehen wir müssen schneller
unabhängig werden von fossilen energien
wir müssen schneller in regenerative
energien investieren in die
infrastruktur aber vor allem auch in die
köpfe und deswegen haben die vorhaben
des koalitionsvertrags eben nichts von
ihrer aktualität und bedeutung verloren
hinzu kommt die aufgabe menschen die
jetzt aus der ukraine zu uns kommen und
hier zuflucht suchen in gesellschaft und
arbeitsmarkt zu integrieren dabei geht
es zuerst mal um die unterbringungen
dach über dem kopf zu haben und schnelle
hilfe dazu gehört auch die
psychologische betreuung denn viele sind
traumatisiert
wir müssen aber auch dafür sorgen und
wir wollen dafür sorgen dass diejenigen
die da zu uns kommen einen beitrag
leisten können dort unsere wirtschaft
unsere unternehmen dringend
arbeitskräfte brauchen es geht um die
anerkennung
von berufsabschlüssen es geht um
kinderbetreuung und um ausreichend
sprachkurse vor diesem hintergrund meine
damen und herren stellen sich für den
bundeshaushalt zwei wesentliche aufgaben
erstens wir müssen die bundesagentur für
arbeit in die lage versetzen dass sie
ihre aufgaben gut leisten kann das gilt
für die kurzfristigen aufgaben
insbesondere bei der kurzarbeit ich habe
es angesprochen und viele vor
rednerinnen und redner auch kurzarbeit
muss weiterhin auch in der ukraine krise
als brücke über die krise funktionieren
kurzarbeit sichert die existenz von
betrieben sichert beschäftigung und
sichern einkommen sichert im übrigen
auch die finanzielle stabilität der
gesetzlichen renten fürsten schon
auf der anderen seite
sind es aber langfristige aufgabe die
fachkräftesicherung und die bewältigung
des strukturwandels unser anspruch als
ampelkoalition ist es jede und eben
individuell in diesem wandel zu
unterstützen durch weiterbildung neue
perspektiven zu schaffen wir wollen
weiterbildungs weltmeister werden und
deshalb dürfen wir die bundesagentur für
arbeit wird diese zukunftsaufgaben nicht
mit weiteren schulden belasten sondern
müssen ihnen einen zuschuss geben damit
sie entschuldet wird und diese aufgaben
angehen kann
zweitens
müssen wir die jobcenter in die lage
versetzen dass sie ihre aufgaben leisten
können dass sie einen beitrag zur
arbeitskräfte sicherung damit zum
besseren unterstützung von
langzeitarbeitslosen leisten können da
haben wir handlungsbedarf denn die
langzeitarbeitslosigkeit ist seit beginn
der pandemie um 200.000 gestiegen und da
haben wir auch chancen potenziale zu
heben und menschen besser zu befähigen
ja und es geht darum dass wir auch
teilhabe für menschen organisiert die
sonst keine perspektiven haben
ab dem 11 201 23 wollen wir das neue
bürgergeld einführen
auch das eine große aufgabe denn wir
wollen einen kulturwandel sicherstellen
da geht es nicht nur darum hier bisschen
mehr leistung und da noch ein instrument
mehr an einem tag jedes um einen
kulturwandel hin zu individueller
unterstützung auf augenhöhe dazu
dazu meine damen und herren kommen in
den kommenden jahren die stabilisierung
der rente verbesserungen für
erwerbsminderungsrentner rinnen und
erwerbsminderungsrentner und ein
umfassendes programm für
barrierefreiheit wir werden in den
haushaltsgesprächen darauf achten dass
all dies auch finanziert wird das gilt
zusammen für drei haushalte für den
haushalt 2022 der heute hier beraten
aber vor allem auch für den ergänzungs
haushalt für die zusatzaufgaben im
zusammenhang mit dem ukraine krieg und
drittens auch für den haushalt 2023 der
ja im juni bereits ins bundeskabinett
kommt und alle weiteren haushalt meine
damen und herren es geht darum die
notwendigen mittel für
zukunftsinvestitionen zu zur verfügung
zu stellen und in sozialen fortschritt
und sozialen zusammenhalt zu investieren
das werden wir als ampel gemeinsam tun
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die cdu csu fraktion
ist der kollege dr stefan hackl den ich
ganz herzlich zu seiner ersten rede im
deutschen bundestag zu brüssel
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen zu den starts
aufgaben zählen klassisch die innere und
äußere sicherheit wägen putins krieg in
der ukraine ukraine sprechen wir aktuell
aus gutem grund viel über äußere
sicherheit über die ausrüstung der
bundeswehr über unsere
verteidigungsfähigkeit und das naso ziel
der 2 prozent in einer modernen
ausdifferenzierten arbeitsgesellschaft
gehört zu den zentralen starts
funktionen aber eben auch die soziale
sicherheit sozialer sicherheit dafür
steht unser sozialstaat es geht um
sozialen frieden um ausgleich um
eröffnung von lebenschancen
innere äußere und soziale sicherheit das
eine kann man nicht ohne das andere
betrachten die kosten die jetzt
unmittelbar auf grund von
wirtschaftssanktionen für die versorgung
von kriegsflüchtlingen und ihre
integration in unsere gesellschaft
entstehen setzen unseren sozialhaushalt
stark unter druck
die ampel versucht das zu verschleiern
indem sich hinter bemühten
differenzierung von kernhaushalt
ergänzungs haushalt und sondervermögen
versteckt die menschen in unserem land
verdienen aber transparenz statt
schattenhaushalte
meine damen und herren wir sehen nicht
erst jetzt sondern schon seit ausbruch
der korona pandemie ängsten
in der bevölkerung verdrängt
zukunftsangst die zuversicht sie als
bundesregierung haben eine besondere
politische verantwortung für die
öffentliche diskussion und ihre
tonalität es ist fahrlässig wenn sie in
diesen schwierigen zeiten das vertrauen
der menschen in die politik noch
zusätzlich schwächen wenn sie bei der
rentenversicherung wie sie es bei der
rentenversicherung tun die zögern jede
auch noch so kleine reform hinaus vor
100 tagen sind sie dynamisch angetreten
sie wollten eine fortschritts koalition
seien aber schon jetzt macht sich
lähmung breit dabei treten sie nicht auf
der stelle
sie legen sondern den rückwärtsgang ein
auf 177 seiten koalitionsvertrag finde
ich keine gemeinsame idee für die rente
stattdessen übernehmen es passagen aus
der allgemeinen prognose der deutschen
rentenversicherung nach der niveau und
beitragsstabilität für die dauer dieser
legislaturperiode als gesichert gelten
aber sie hätten weiter lesen müssen
diese prognosen besagen nämlich auch das
unmittelbar nach ende dieser legislatur
die kurven auseinandergehen und die
haltelinien gerissen werden das können
sie doch nicht einfach ignorieren wo es
ihr konzept
sie wollen unsere werte
umlagefinanzierte rente für den zeitraum
in dem die babyboomer in den ruhestand
gehen durch einkünfte aus dem
finanzmarkt entlasten ihre dafür
angekündigten 10 milliarden euro sind
aus dem haushaltsentwurf verschwunden
wenn sie es ernst meinen müssen sie aber
jetzt anfangen einen kapitalstock zu
bilden aber davon abgesehen ist die
verzinsung von zehn milliarden euro
angesichts eines jahres volumens in der
rente von über 300 milliarden euro einen
hauch um nichts kein unterschied die
union steht mit ihrer kritik nicht
alleine da auch der deutsche
gewerkschaftsbund
warnt vor einem griff in die rentenkasse
dgb vorstandsmitglied anja biewald
kritisiert dass bundesfinanzminister
lindner das sicherheitsversprechen für
die rente einfach aufkündigt dass die
ampel noch zu jahresende in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag gegeben hat
stattdessen hat die ampel die
gesetzliche für die jahre 2002 und 20
bis 25 festgeschriebene jährliche
sonderzahlung von 500 millionen euro
einfach auf null gekürzt ich finde das
rechtswidrig und das vertrauen
lieber herr heil wenn sie in der
nächsten zeit ihren koalitionsvertrag
neu aushandeln müssen weil der ukraine
krieg auch ihr politisches
koordinatensystem durcheinander gebracht
hat
berücksichtigen sie doch bitte das thema
rente angemessen die rente darf nicht
schlechtgeredet werden unser
umlagefinanzierte system ist gut ist
bedarf nur angesichts sich immer wieder
verändernden gesellschaftlichen
rahmenbedingungen einer stetigen
nachsteuerung es geht nicht um weniger
als um die anerkennung der
lebensleistung von generationen und
zugleich um das im blick behalten der
leistungsfähigkeit der jüngeren und der
belastbarkeit der jüngeren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
vertrauen in die rente wird nur dann
wachsen wenn die verschiedenen
politischen richtungen an einem strang
ziehen so war es unsere gute tradition
gerne erinnere ich an dieser stelle an
meinen leider viel zu früh verstorbenen
politischen mentor karl schiewerling die
mit von ihnen die von ihm mit geleitete
kommission
verlässlicher generationenvertrag hat
viele themen an diskutiert lassen sie
uns weitere schritte auf dieser basis
machen frei nach erich kästner es gibt
nichts gutes außer man tut es vielen
dank
[Applaus]
vielen dank für die rede sie haben auch
die redezeit eingehalten bei ihrer
ersten rede sogar noch ein paar sekunden
liegen lassen herzlichen glückwunsch
dazu und alles gute für ihre weitere
arbeit hier im haus
und der nächste redner hat sich schon
ins boot begeben für die fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen und markus kurth
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich glaube jetzt ist an dieser
debatte der punkt gekommen wo man die
cdu/csu mal politisch versteht sich am
schlafittchen packen muss wenn sie hier
auch ihre erfolgsbilanz verweisen und
auch
verantwortungsvolle politik hinweisen
dann muss man hier der redlichkeit
halber feststellen dass die guten jahre
zwischen der finanzkrise und der korona
krise mit höchster beschäftigung wo die
einnahmen sprudelten die sozialkassen
sich von selbst füllten nicht vorsorge
von ihnen betrieben worden ist wo
stünden wir
wenn sie in der letzten wahlperiode als
das qualifizierungs chancen gesetz kam
nicht im bremserhäuschen gestanden
hätten und zum beispiel bei der
weiterbildung mutigere schritte gemacht
hätten das wäre noch möglich gewesen
in der letzten wahlperiode als der
soziale arbeitsmarkt oder
teilhabechancen gesetzt kam was wir sehr
unterstützt haben als bündnis 90 die
grünen da waren es doch sie die das
befristet haben und dadurch
planungsunsicherheit bei den jobcentern
gesorgt haben das war keine
verantwortungsvolle politik
und bei der grundrente als sie
eingeführt wurde die von der
grundsystematik her ja durchaus unserer
garantierente entsprach da waren es doch
sie vorwiegend die das ganze bürokratie
aufgehalten und intransparent gestaltet
haben all die möglichkeiten all die
möglichkeiten die in der regierungszeit
lagen die sie hatten als es gut lief
haben sie verspielt und da wo sie in
verantwortung sind betreiben sie das
spiel ja weiter ich finde es geradezu
unfassbar dass markus söder in bayern
immer noch an den abstandsregeln für die
windräder festhält das müssen sie sich
mal vorstellen in dieser situation und
herr frey das ist durchaus zum thema
denn das ist wirtschaftspolitisch
sinnvoll der ausbau der erneuerbaren und
gerade mit windkraft es ist
sicherheitspolitisch sinnvoll wie wir
wissen klimapolitisch sowieso und es hat
einen effekt auf den arbeitsmarkt und
das ist wirklich nicht vergessen und
verantwortungslos was sie an dieser
stelle hier betreiben und darum lassen
wir uns hier von der ampel koalition
überhaupt nichts von ihnen sagen was
mangelnde verantwortungsübernahme
anbelangt und von ihnen herr stracke von
der csu von der partei von herrn söder
lassen wir uns doch hier nicht vorhalten
wir müssen noch mehr machen das
entlastungspaket würde nicht groß genug
ausfallen haben sie gesagt das muss
jemand sagen der noch bis vor sechs
monaten sozialpolitisch im
bremserhäuschen gesessen hat und das
lassen wir eigentlich durchgehend vielen
dank
nächste rednerin für die cdu csu
fraktion dr silke laune
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin lieber
herr bundesminister liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen sehr geehrte damen und
herren wir sprechen heute hier über den
etat des bundesministeriums für arbeit
und soziales also die finanziellen
mittel die der haushalt vorsieht für das
arbeitsministerium
ich würde trotzdem betonen weil das
natürlich ich weiß das gerät in einer
debatte immer so ein bisschen in
vergessenheit aber das ist eigentlich
der tagesordnungspunkt und deshalb
sollten wir vielleicht auch ein bisschen
noch mehr zum haushalt es sagen das geht
natürlich
für mich als die zuständige haushälterin
für diesen bereich und ich weiß dass das
nicht so gerne gehört wird dass man
bezahlen kommt wo man doch was gutes tun
will aber ich sage ihnen eins es hängt
zusammen man kann nur gutes tun wenn
nicht vorher auch vernünftig langfristig
gut planung mit dem geld sinnvoll umgeht
das weiß jede familie und es geht auch
für den staat
hier haben wir den größten
einzelhaushalt über
160 mehr
und dieser uns vorliegende übrigens erst
anfang letzter woche zugeschickte zweite
entwurf des einzel plans denn es kann
jetzt noch veränderungen corona krise
wird teurer werden jetzt kam der krieg
dazu deshalb erst anfang letzter woche
ist eigentlich schon so nicht mehr
haltbar
diese 160 milliarden werden das kann man
schon jetzt ablesen nicht ansatzweise
das sein was dann letztlich wirklich
rauskommt warum nicht wie dann doch
erwartet also die großen herausforderung
zusammenhang mit dem ukraine krieg ist
es schon angesprochen worden es wird
durch die verteuerung von öl und gas zu
erheblichen nachteilen bei den betrieben
zu kurzarbeitergeld kommen was natürlich
dazu führt dass der staat dann durch
zuschüsse unterstützt die agentur für
arbeit es wird eben neben dem kurzarbeit
auch vielleicht zu neuen kosten im
hinblick auf arbeitsmigration wenn es zu
arbeitslosen kommt geld kommen durch die
flüchtlingswelle werden wir erhebliche
steigerung haben sei dies bei sprach
schulungskurs sind langfristig natürlich
dann auch im sozial bei dem
sozialbereich am anfang machen uns ja
noch die kommunen das heißt auch jetzt
ist absehbar dass in triesen beträge das
kommt dann alles erst in einem
ergänzungs haushalt den wir nicht kennen
ich hoffe wir sehen ihn bald das zeigt
welche fass wir haben macht es reicht
nicht es geht weiter denn gestern einen
tag vor der debatte hören wir dann von
dem paket nicht begrüße in der sache das
paket es ist gut dass endlich was
passiert seit wochen ja seit monaten
wird dafür gekämpft und nun kommt
endlich was allerdings ist es uns
gegenüber und scheu frechheit einen tag
vor der debatte also wir haben eine
dreifache völlig überholten haushalt
über die wir hier reden 160 milliarden
nicht
das widerspiegelt was es in wahrheit
geht
das hat mit den grundsätzen dass man
sich sehr verhält eigentlich nichts mehr
zu tun im haushalt bereit und es wundert
mich besonders von der fdp
nicht nur dass er jetzt schon bei dem
rückständig also schon dreimal
überholten etwa 100 milliarden ungefähr
kredit haben das noch ohne mehr am
zusätzlich kommen dass man vorher 60
milliarden an der schuldenbremse vorbei
gemogelt hat für den energie und
klimafonds nicht nur das
nein wir machen solche spielchen kurz
vor schluss noch als wir wissen
überhaupt gar nicht richtig über was wir
reden dass man wird von der fdp gelernt
wir haben uns vier vorträge anhalten
lassen über haushaltswahrheit und
klarheit und generationengerechtigkeit
alles vergessen der wald wiese geführt
worden alles vergessen
der lizenzvertrag vielleicht wollen sie
man den eigenen koalitionsvertrag hören
was anwender also wir werden da die
gesetzliche rente stärken und das
mindestrente niveau von 48 prozent
dauerhaft sichern
sie wissen es selbst es war klar
geregelt oder ist es wird jetzt von
heute auf morgen wenn man schnell
schnell abschaffen
287 500 milliarden
500 millionen jedes jahr von 20 22 20 25
soll als sonderzahlung in die
gesetzliche rentenversicherung der regen
sich die eigenen dgb vorstellen der auf
unglaublich griff indirekten karte haben
wir von heute auf morgen eingespart
übrigens ist eine milliarde zwei jahren
ein wertvoller beitrag zur
stabilisierung der beiträge einfach mal
rausgeflogen findet sich in position
dazu vertrag nichts nochmal
koalitionsentwurf nichts mama
koalitionsvertrag
wortwörtlich dazu werden wir in einem
kasten schritt der deutschen
rentenversicherung im jahr 20 22 war das
mit dezember also im dezember haben wir
versprochen 20 22 aus den
haushaltsmitteln füllen den kapitalstock
es geht um die ergänzung der aktien
unterstützten handy zehn jahren
koalitionsvertrag 10 millionen
21 sein haus etwas finden wir ein wurf
nichts
das ist wirklich alles andere als eine
klare wahl seriöse generationengerechte
haushaltsplanung die herr leben ist es
ein desaster und es wird nämlich
weitergehen wenn wir weiter so machen
ist es nicht nur lindner leider jetzt
der schuldenkönig zeichnet sich ab hat
sich noch über den stolz lustig macht
jetzt ist er selbst nein es wird uns
auch noch in europa teuer kommen wenn
wir selbst nicht mehr ansatzweise das
erfüllen was wir eigentlich wieder in
kraft setzen wollen
meine oma eine sehr leben verfahren die
leider auch kriegs afrika eine frau hat
gesagt ich habe nicht immer alles
verstanden und nicht jeder wunsch von
mir ist beschlossen worden aber unter
den schwarz ist uns immer besser
gegangen und sie haben noch was gesagt
die linken versprechen alles und halten
nichts
[Applaus]
nächste rednerin für die spd-fraktion
roshana
werte kollegin launert ich glaube nach
dieser rede hat sich noch einmal
deutlich gezeigt warum es richtig ist
dass es jetzt neue
regierungsmehrheiten in diesem land gibt
die veranstaltung
auch präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren werte kolleginnen und
kollegen meine eltern sind 1986 aus
syrien in die ddr gekommen um ihr
studium der architektur an der tu
dresden zu beenden und als dann die
wiedervereinigung kamen haben sie sich
dazu entschieden hier zu bleiben um sich
mein bruder und später dann auch mal
eine bessere perspektive bieten zu
können meine eltern haben ihre heimat
damals freiwillig verlassen sie haben
sie es hier möglich eine existenz
aufgebaut und hatten dabei nicht immer
nur glück aber glück seien wir ehrlich
entscheidet leider immer noch viel zu
häufig darüber werden diesem land etwas
werden kann und in den letzten jahren
sind immer mehr menschen nicht
freiwillig zu uns gekommen sondern
wunder zu gezwungen wenn menschen ihre
heimat verlieren dann ist es unsere
oberste pflicht in schutz und zuflucht
zu gewähren
diese menschen dann bei uns egal ob sie
geflüchtet sind oder aus welchem grund
auch immer sie station entschieden haben
zu uns zu kommen dann ist es doch auch
unsere oberste pflicht ihnen alle
chancen zu geben sich hier eine eigene
perspektive aufbauen zu können und an
dieser stelle will ich kurz auf die
situation in der ukraine zu sprechen
kommen mittlerweile vier wochen dauert
dieser grausamen krieg an und mir
persönlich macht es mut dass wir nicht
nur in unserer härte gegenüber putin
sondern auch in unserem mitgefühl
gegenüber den menschen in der ukraine
vereins sind und dieses mitgefühl das
lässt sich auch politisch erkennen und
deswegen hoffe ich inständig dass das
jetzt der moment ist in dem wir unseren
umgang mit flucht migration und
integration auch und vor allem in
unseren arbeitsmarkt grundlegend
überdenken
dezember letzten jahres und des ersten
entwurfs für unseren haushalt sind noch
einmal über zehn millionen euro
zusätzlich für den bereich
fachkräftesicherung im einzelplan es
festgehalten das ist gut so denn für
große zukunftsaufgaben müssen oft große
zukunftsinvestitionen getätigt werden
und ich zitiere an dieser stelle mit
erlaubnis der präsident in den
staatssekretär im bundesinnenministerium
bmi der letztens treffend formuliert hat
wir müssen aufhören den leuten zu sagen
du musst gehen weil sondern müssen
anfangen zu sagen du kannst bleiben wenn
und deswegen sind wir hier in der bring
fließt werte kolleginnen und kollegen
den arbeitsmarkt integration ist eine
der größten aufgaben unserer zeit
lassen sie uns zuwanderung doch bitte
endlich auch als chance erkennen denn
wir sind doch schon längst ein
einwanderungsland meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren punkt wir sind
angewiesen auf die klugen köpfe von nah
und fern und dabei meine ich nicht nur
jene die bereits mit hochschulabschluss
oder doktortitel zu uns kommen sondern
auch jene die als fachkräfte aus so
vielen bereichen jetzt schon gar nicht
mehr wegzudenken sind ohne unsere
kolleginnen aus dem ausland geht's nicht
mehr und deshalb müssen wir dafür sorgen
dass menschen einen niedrigschwelligen
zugang zum deutschen arbeitsmarkt
bekommen und daher müssen wir aber auch
darauf achten dass das spiel nach
unseren regeln wollte dazu gehören unter
anderem ordentliche arbeitsbedingungen
und vereine faire entlohnung von
mindestens 12 euro die stunde am besten
aber nach tarif und dann müssen alle
diente provokativ monster daran das
haben wir uns auch als koalition
festgehalten denn der spitze bleiben
will der muss sich auch bewegen also
lassen sie uns gemeinsam dafür sorgen
dass der deutsche arbeitsmarkt auch in
zukunft attraktiv bleibt und noch besser
wird sowohl für unsere eigenen leute als
auch für die vielen klugen köpfe die es
fachkräfte hier zu uns kommen und auf
die wir angewiesen sind und
perspektivisch noch mehr sein werden und
lassen sie uns schließlich dafür kämpfen
dass eben nicht mehr glück darüber
entscheidet wer was werden kann sondern
dass in diesem wunderbaren land alle
alles werden können die ampel ist bereit
dafür vielen dank
damit endet die aussprache zum
[Musik]
haushaltsplan arbeit und soziales
einzelplan 11